learning that someone hates us deeply
even though we've done nothing
ostensibly to provoke them can be one of
the most slamming situations we face
because of Technology it's also liable
to happen to us
more and more in the past our enemies
were restricted to the vicinity
now they lice scattered around the
digital planet in the past we might once
have unwisely read about ourselves in
another's diary now we can make the
baleful error of quietly googling our
own name being hated feels so serious
for three central reasons because we see
the hatred as a prelude to genuine
practical danger because we feel that
those who hate us might be right that
their negative information though
unpleasant might have something
important to teach us and because we
implicitly trust in the basic wisdom
soundness of mind and suggestive the
person delivering the attack but each of
these reasons is liable to be badly off
the mark
once upon a time our enemy might have
come to bludgeon us in the night no
wonder we were very concerned but now
almost always they can only ever impose
a psychological wound their ill-will is
unrelated to further action and yet it's
as if an ancestral part of our minds had
failed to notice our freedom that we no
longer live in tribes and that we can
flourish independently in the vast and
appoints delightfully anonymous cities
of modernity unhampered by the narrow
verdict of a few corrupt judges part of
our vulnerability to hatred stems from
the poignant and at origin intelligent
way we tend to keep an open mind about
criticism we know at heart rightly that
we have so much to learn from other
people so we continue to behave like the
trusting school children we once were
waiting to receive the opinions of
broadly benevolent teachers but this
important capacity to learn may lack the
necessary limits what starts off as a
virtue can in time leads to a desperate
unnecessary vulnerability to any
incoming information and eventually a
kind of madness as we leave ourselves
open to attack
by those who plainly don't have our best
interests at heart
we're seldom very good at filtering with
our enemies are well-qualified judges of
our right to exist in our panic at the
news of hatred we fail to ask ourselves
the one important question whether there
is any truth in the attack but even when
criticism is correct we should never
surrender our self-love to anyone who
delivers it to us drenched in contempt
there is never any excuse for cruelty we
should distinguish between the critic
and the hater whereas the critic limits
the psychological significance and fall
out of their point of contention the
hater takes a small point of
disagreement as a way of access to
deliver a wholesale bitter condemnation
of us as human beings there is a vast
difference between declaring you're full
of [ __ ] and clearing the throat to
say I think you're mistaken on this
point the first move suggests that your
error is a consequence of a fundamental
rottenness the second leaves open that
you could be an honorable soul who just
happens to be like so many of us
understandably confused on a complicated
issue we should ultimately trust that
anyone who deliberately harms us must be
a highly damaged and therefore
unreliable witness we should not
continue to believe that they may be
frustrated but clever like an
exasperated but fundamentally wise
teacher motivated by a pursuit of the
truth
however roughly handled if one was truly
wise insightful and mature one could
never want to make another person
collapse internally the desire to hurt a
stranger can only have big and troubled
explanations behind it
something distorting their judgment and
stripping them of the right to destroy
our self-confidence with impunity none
of us are blameless we all have so much
growing up to do a distinct openness to
criticism is key to our self-development
but we should aim for a confident
distinction between the hater and the
critic we should be worried only by our
genuine flaws and otherwise forgive the
injured roaring beasts who seek to
punish us for their own unev out
Oh rose
you